[Music]
coming inter inter put him right there
put him right
there
[Music]
1583 I'm dragging my
I'm
[Music]
guys
I'm get up on the
[Music]
inter
329 keep them poed on what Lane they're
[Music]
in
look
like he wants to go back south down
[Music]
when you get up here I'm going to switch
in trying to do a roll on stops
try to
[Music]
hit back
around
someone on
[Applause]
44y stopy
stop it's him it's him it's
him you stupid
dude
[Music]
57 65 stop talking no I don't want
nobody showing up you can't touch you I
am I'm touching you right now you're
under arrest I don't want anyone else
coming here calling nobody he 17 stop
walking stop talking stop
talking so 286 for the
a pursuit of a twoone S10 wanted for
homicide eastbound on ash from 11 it's
matches the description of a homicide
vehicle freshly painted it's going to be
black and cutter in the front silver in
the back two occupant Ted Windows Poli
behind us
o two
o
North on Street
truck we going to be going Southbound
onth Street
approaching
approximately West 43 North shiff
please
[Music]
[Applause]
approximately 86 they're
do Center C reaching down low dece proba
[Applause]
arm
traffic is medium right now speed
approximately 6 roads are dry silver
black tone Chevy pickup trucked for
vehicle homicide two
occs s indicate inside
[Music]
the we are taking the disregard not
taking the 30
ACC traffic is medium are approximately
80 vehicle is sped and Signal changing
multiple
Lanes on
nor5 take take
[Applause]
[Music]
mil
silver and black 10 for vehicle
homicide
[Music]
[Applause]
hour guys
W mil hour traffic is pretty heavy right
here
[Applause]
drive name instead of an ex
number
want some
water here
[Music]
drive field
[Applause]
[Music]
here
taking
[Applause]
[Music]
right
here see if they can get some
spes on
hello okay sounds
good still on 43
sou you already said who are you talking
to
of out
56 uh yeah we're
primary we have a couple of uh Unown
spots
[Applause]
still3
approaching
miles wanted
a
black
Spike good Spike left
tire still approaching crazy
bro uh passing approaching Waterford
moano exit exit
43 approaching number
43 front tire should be going
down front tire stting a good way he's
still on Second Lane still 43 three
tires deflated three three tires back
right tires also
stuck slowing down mile marker 42
slowing down way down slowing down down
number
[Music]
42 got me
stay inside keep your hands
[Music]
up walk towards my
voice step to the right step to the
right
it's walk to the sound of my voice keep
coming back keep walking backwards keep
facing away from
me your up
backwards are you
hurt are you hurt how old are you 19 19
okay you got
ID
noar well mean you can't flee like that
I know I'm saying I'm not trying to go
nowhere I'm like I'm you're fine just a
lot of attention I'm calm right here I
know I just did what I just did my name
but I'm not I'm not what's your name
resisting you like physically or okay
what's your
name
got you're good man you're good well we
can pull this car to the side whose car
is
this what you seem you're good you're
good eastbound
[Music]
Rober you got eyes
on
in the
Southbound
[Music]
fter
Southbound
I might lost it here
[Music]
traic go go di I don't know where he
went somebody monitor their Channel and
keep us updated where they
are we lost him so if you can bring it
let us know he going too fast for
us yeah it's
now Chopper within free
FL
fre there
[Music]
don't
street name not bi
markers oh he can't run anywhere if
you're going to pit him we can put him
into the
wall 217 over 6 is lit up he's taken off
mission to 503 reevis go
ahead right
already
up8 no box hit when you can out of
traffic
though left left lane approaching 303
right now going by 84 M 85
mph set up
[Music]
car
take him out
[Music]
Jason
you be contact take by Miss Northbound
on primary 13 1539 take
[Music]
radio Okay Northbound on Prim
radio at 230 going into the county line
now 1858 from a distance slowing
down around possible
South P don't pit not around traffic you
got to try take it
[Music]
F
fast right lane
lane 90
[Music]
mph radio too fast
fast that's
[Music]
right right approach turn FL right fir
coming back over now left hand lane left
hand lane left hand lane right here
right in front of
me take him
[Music]
out
down 230 back
souting off of 82 off 82 southbound to
[Music]
82 up 82 right now up 82 hit some
traffic here going uh West on 82 West on
[Music]
82 47 unit out to
82 82 permission to continue Pursuit
heavy traffic on
82 go ahead with it you need to continue
to pursue until Aviation get there any
opportunity to pit we need to take
[Music]
it 42 82 going west 73 mph heavy traffic
all green light so far coming through
[Music]
here 82 West approaching
42 82 West approaching
42 one
82 Prospect going west still still going
[Music]
west here North on
57 all coming in construction North on
[Music]
57 7 North 57 North 72 mph hit the
traffic here like traffic
[Music]
we on
20b 57 from
Chestnut I'm parallel on
[Music]
83 100 Northbound in the southbound lane
57 North and
CH 17 21's
[Music]
out
1602 what's the
status one that gun for right now we're
getting them out right gun
point
coming up behind you up
[Music]
behind
1060 are you primary
now
right okay what's your
speed
[Music]
green if you could see pgpd as
identified those who they
[Music]
are 183 bgpd does not have any kind of
identification no plate they left any
U-Haul okay 1060 do you have a
registration on
6 all
right ATK
89114 you Edward Adam
go you advis you took 475
[Music]
correct okay Mommy and T
advice 183 you canise MP you haven't
already super can just somebody at the
state
line
[Music]
okay right lane
speed right lane speed
70 1493 are you able get set up tomor
cross
[Music]
river crossing the river 72
speed exiting at
[Music]
24 AC at
24 approaching the 24 exit head
some
475 continue 475 going to
change okay still on
[Music]
475 left lanane
75 M must front of
eyes the
[Music]
left F at this crossover you're coming
up
too
okay
FL
[Music]
on0
1060 out the radio traffic be North B
475 12 over
[Music]
4 Contin Mission we
terminate
okay ter St line I the with MSP they are
aware of
that North left
[Music]
LAN
look going
[Music]
on
going
[Music]
get
overs
to all
right Freddy's going to turn on Spring
at this he's right there in front of
him eastbound Springs dude eastbound
Springs we're going to be South on
island South on island nor find North
jacks I know
long
go on
[Music]
Al okay nor Austin Town towarda
good
[Music]
I wasn't too far I thought guys
live okay we're just about coming up to
uh
okay Northbound on Main Street
northbound Main
Street we just passed an OSP but I don't
know if he's going to get involved or
not wa to
see
watch there's a four-wheeler to your
[Music]
left okay he's coming down Second Street
[Applause]
West just watch where
are
45 okay North 145 North
145 correction high high more
car try to cut up first
down shoot anything back on Liberty and
we're going to be turning westbound on
West Market westbound West Market
nothing is it
yet
oh okay
bub Mar
pass does have charges they F
today what
they
it nor on
lit bar trying to get out there by the
schol
see
feeling down nor Park
Park we're coming up to 11 State Road
right by wa
[Music]
night
AV turn sou found
yet
okay he turning South on out South on
[Music]
out be getting on the bypass 82 see if
how can get up on the bypass Go
[Music]
pass he's not the byass
M okay
christas you know do
have try and cut you guys
off okay we're still eastbound on
we're coming up to use Market coming up
to use
Market
okay we're getting off of these Market
we're getting off of these
market and Westbound westbound
Market
okay he's turning on North Ro
South through
the
[Music]
and we're back east on East Market
Street
okay any word on
how okay we're going to be going in
Island on East y Street Judy towards
your
Plaza you can advise me
okay he is northb 46 Northbound
[Music]
matter going
keep
[Music]
now he's going down some real track
now
we're on some railroad there's a gravel
drive
for
going
hey
hey what you want to
[Music]
do
hey quit closing the
open the
[Music]
door 1150 Cleveland I'm
in
[Music]
every two black
males getting off on
21 spe
[Music]
109 light traffic light got off at the
making a ride on ra
maker residential area right speed
40 there is light sow on the
[Music]
road a residential
area
[Music]
okay making a right on Fry Road just
blew a red light making a left on
[Music]
snow
again
okay
[Music]
last I just saw him get back south on 71
and I go
after 504 is at the
232 we can set spikes what kind of car
is
it the White Station
Wagon that no lights
on
right
behind 11
we
okay 653 pay attention up
[Music]
there you need to get those people out
of there he's coming in hot into that 31
area
[Music]
there some more spes out here I'm
not
do
[Music]
coming
in got a
[Music]
passenger 31 31
hey back up back up back back
[Music]
your yes I
have is on
driver get out stay there the glass
watch out
move get out
now you got the second one coming out
get out there
your
back you just put everyone in
days
40 32
priority I got a fusion a Kia and
another R
SUV back check that hand of fourth
vehicle and we're going to be heading
north possibly towards the bridge
accident
103 there's four vehicles four
vehicles four
vehicles 32 I'm backing off coming up to
Rook bik
[Applause]
on
out
[Music]
towards
a and up over the curb towards Right Aid
he's Eastbound and the westbound on
[Music]
6th 432 we have conf that PL as a
v
[Music]
losing it at kou lost it at kou
northeast corner vehicle rolled over
start
[Music]
Medical
stra
weing
pleaseing
out oh he's going
they're going to be continuing going to
be eastbound on
[Music]
gon
pass
[Music]
michig in the library right here right
here clear into the
library
go left go right go right he's going
right he's going
[Music]
right
left right
[Music]
right go way down go
down
come on come
on stay in stay
[Music]
in
got
got left left left left
[Music]
left
from
all right 6 to the
[Music]
right
you
[Music]
West Memphis
bre down break
[Music]
down everybody
got